tanaka
towing the slab into boogie down here
tonight
with the nypd hat on you can see this
would be his a start
on the year and it'll be also in his
career as a yankee his 170
career start and we'll begin the game
with cedric mullins who
tries to bun his way on it's a dead end
but near third and no
chance for the mayhew you don't get that
lean or that running start makes it much
more difficult
there he goes to throw in time he threw
a bullet
the tag applied by estrada two-in-one
on iglesias and here's a fly ball left
field
gardner's there to make the play for the
second half we're scoreless with two
outs in the top of the first
dj stewart stepping in stewart with a
drive into right
field d.j stewart is back on the horse
after an 0 for 3 game one he hits a home
run for the fifth time in
six games and the orioles strike first
in game two in the bronx 2-2
swing and a miss and that will do it
there is keegan aiken from alma michigan
drafted by the orioles in the second
round back in 2016 out of western
michigan
with second and third this is clint
frazier
hit shortly to short they're gonna come
home with the throw
it is not handled by cisco and the game
is tied at one
first and second there's glaiber torres
line drive that's a base hit to left
center field
rounding third is voigt they're sending
him home here's the throw it's
way off line so an rbi single for torres
the other runners move up
and it's 2-1 yankees orioles bring the
infield in
second and third for miguel and duhar
that one is driven to left field that
ball is
one hop up against the wall two runs
score
and duhar with a two run double and the
yankees lead four to one
your defense doesn't help you and all of
a sudden it begins to snowball
that will help high fastball to strike
out
sanchez two down a full mile an hour on
average
quicker this year for tanaka
swinging to miss it's in the dirt
sanchez makes the throw to void so it's
a strikeout put out 2-3
and lakins cuts the fastball for strike
three
strike three mount castle down looking
seven in a row retired by tanaka
you're starting to see tanaka find that
control again and just
dotting the corner with this slider
right here runners lead first and second
noah now
that one's driven deep to center field
mullins back still back
on the track at the wall see ya into the
yankee bullpen
a three-run shot for voight and the
yankees lead
seven to one looks like the footstep
works
even on the home run but you can see the
flip of the bat
that luke voigt knew he got this one and
this is probably a knockout punch
for the yankees have turned laborious
into runs torres rips this one in the
hole to short stopping glaciers gloves
into second for one on to first make
that two
a beautifully turned double play by the
orioles
that was a work of art by jose and
glaciers
deep in the hole it's short got it to
hanser alberto
who spun around to davis for the 6-4-3
double play
grounded to first voight's right there
steps on the back masahiro has retired
three
six nine he's retired 12 in a row
only mike trout has hit more home runs
than luke voight and luke is tied with
fernando tatis jr and nelson cruz with
15.
driven out to left field and deep going
back mount castle he's on the track at
the wall
sia mike trout has company 16th home run
for luke voight another three run
shot and the yankees lead ten to one
so six ribbies on two swings big night
offensively for luke point
so brooks krisky will try to get the
final three outs of this one
strike three holiday tosses the bat away
he's halfway to first base
doesn't realize he struck out plenty of
reasons to be aggravated
swinging into miss balaka down on
strikes
and the yankees are one out away from a
doubleheader sweep
and the 2-2 hits sharply but
right to estrada and that will do it
as the yankees win this one 10-1 ball
game over
yankees win the yankees
win well they sweep the doubleheader
in what was a wonderful day for the
yankees